[Music]
Kristen Bell and her kids surprised Dax
Shepard and it's the cutest thing you'll
see all day in this instant the good
play star and her daughter's Delta and
Lincoln can be seen dancing and singing
outside a second-story window while Dax
self quarantines amid coronavirus
concerns Kristen explained in the
caption that Dax had been traveling so
to be cautious she asked him to stay at
a friend's empty apartment for a few
days to make sure he had no symptoms
adding quote today we were missing him
so much we did the only logical thing we
could do dance outside his window to a
Ben Platt and dear Evan Hanson serenade
over the past few days Kristen has been
sharing a bunch of posts about social
distancing and why people should stay
home amid the pandemic and in true bel
fashion she brought a little humor to it
sharing clips and memes like this -
thank you guys and this
[Applause]
meanwhile stars like Jennifer Lopez and
Ciara are getting creative during
quarantine
[Music]
yeah that's the whole crew JLo a rod and
all their kiddos working some serious
choreography a pregnancy era danced to
the same song with her family marking
her first family tick tock post then
there's Jessica Alba still no then what
do you have a life jess has officially
proven she's not just a regular mom
she's a cool mom doing full-blown dance
routines with our kids on tick tock but
to send you off let's watch Kristen and
her fam one more time
[Music]